you're one of the bigger sponsors for
arnold in regards to the arnold classic
he does every year which apparently
quarter million people show up in ohio
every single year one day that's a
massive
i've never been to arnold classic yeah i
hear it's just something else even
in some cases even bigger than olympia
when it comes down to people
in terms of the expo and the amount of
events they're they're not even close to
be honest the actual the actual
bodybuilding show itself they're they're
i would say the olympia is still ahead
of course um but the actual event no
it's not any close why do you think that
is you you do you uh arnold has a lot of
events there so everything from here let
me let me not go on the olympia side
because that always gets me in trouble
although i'm gonna get in trouble i'm
comfortable with this so go back to uh
arnold classics so
you normally sponsor and it's not like
it's a ten dollar spa ten thousand
dollar response about fifty thousand
you're spending hundreds of thousands of
dollars on everything
what caused you to not wanna support the
arnold classic so it's pretty it's
pretty simple you know i saw that um
that clip of him saying you know if you
don't wear a mask you take a vaccine
you're a [ __ ] or schmuck and if it
bothers you and it messes with your
freedoms a little bit screw your
freedoms
and it just really rubbed me the wrong
way me and my wife i mean we watched it
we were on a trip a vacation my first
week vacation ever um we went to um uh
we went to montana and then wyoming so
nice it was really it was really cool
brought all the kids and it was a great
trip so we're on the trip and we saw the
clip and she and me watched it and i'm
like you know both of us
watching are like damn that really sucks
that he said that and then the the
arnold's coming up and they want you
know they want uh us to be the exclusive
sponsor of the webcast we were one of
the five main sponsors of the show we
were doing uh stuff with the after party
we were very very involved um and the
guy the main guy brian powers who's
really running the event right now is
calling me and texting every day and
it's like for advice and stuff and i was
on the or was going to be on the panel
that helped arnold and advised him on
how to continue to grow the festival and
stuff
and uh and i'm like you know i told her
i'm like damn this guy came from austria
had had nothing created this the empire
this this uh iconic you know
brand arnold brand everything about him
is great i love him i looked up to him
as a kid and now he says this and uh if
he stayed in austria he wouldn't be [ __ ]
he'd be like a charismatic farmer or
something you know like what would he be
he'd be a police officer or whatever i
mean what was the upside what's the
potential the reason why he get famous
is because joe eater gave him an
opportunity to move to america him and
franco started their own business and he
went to college and he got with the
movies and became i mean everything he's
done is so awesome something i really
look up to i love arnold's rules of
success great book by the total recall
if you haven't read it you've got to
re-totally recall yeah arnold's rules
for success he's probably got a few
hundred million views with that one
speech he gives everybody that's a great
video i love i love the one of the ones
i like the best is you know i think he's
i think it's six hours of sleep so if
you need any more you sleep faster
yes i know i love that so so that was
that was a reason for you to step away
so yeah so seeing that you know uh it
just i needed to i felt like it wasn't
right um to support him financially
not that i didn't love the show i mean
i'd love to be going this weekend you
know it's come up this weekend i would
love to be there i love to i enjoy the
show it's actually a good show for the
brand we have tons of fans that come but
it didn't feel right it didn't feel
right to support him so i made a video
that was very specific that i wanted to
make sure don't that i'm not saying
cancel arnold i'm not saying don't go do
what you think is right very classy you
didn't disrespect them i didn't want it
and i wanted it to be you know where
i guess i'm obviously not for cancel
culture i just think that people need to
support
people or not support people with their
dollars so as a business owner or even
an individual consumer like if you don't
believe what the thing stands for you
actually are making a difference you're
able to vote by not giving the dollars
so to send them a few hundred thousand
bucks just felt really wrong so that was
it we did the video and then the the
blowback was like incredible you know
hundreds of stories from everything from
usa today to daily mail to the hill to
everybody everybody covered it but aaron
i mean i'm a huge arnold fan man and you
know in in all fairness to him
you know like you said he comes from
austria so maybe you know english second
language type of thing like maybe it's
like
don't screw the maid like maybe it's the
opposite
so that's the stuff that that's the
stuff that i did maybe it's like you
know he said like screw your freedoms
the same way somebody said arnold don't
screw the maid and he's like oh so screw
the maid yeah
no i don't know maybe maybe that's what
arnold look you know in in that uh the
comment when that comment was made i
mean i had arnold's posters in my room
for god knows how many years i'm sure
you did you know the posters he's got
the muscle one of the best ones was the
one with muscle magazine black and white
of him posing i had it it's beautiful 24
by 36. i would buy all those magazines
just for that just for that yeah when he
had specials you always bought the
special muscle mic flex edition arnold
edition
he's standing on the rnc stage screaming
at the country not to be economic girly
men remember this i mean that this was
he he's smoking his stogies
everywhere
you can't smoke a stogie in your in your
house i can because i'm a man you know
like this he is the physical embodiment
of freedom he is the physical embodiment
of don't tell me what to do and then
he's got the absolute temerity the gall
to say screw your freedoms this isn't
about you because i am older and i've
already lived my dreams go stay in the
house until i feel safe screw arnold man
so so quarter uh are they still
expecting to have 250 000 people show up
or i seriously doubt it so now they have
the mask mandate where every single
person in columbus must wear a mask
everywhere they go you know outside
competitors that we don't know that we
don't know what i thought it does that
oh my gosh those pictures are going to
be hilarious if they make competitors
wear a mask i don't think they will i
mean i talk to uh my good friend they'll
have more covering their face than the
rest of their body i talked to my good
friend uh jim mannion about it and he
said that he does not there's no
intention of having more masks on stage
so i sure i sure hope they don't because
that'll be so ridiculous i know a lot of
competitors are not happy about that
what does jim manion think about arnold
classic
uh well it's the second biggest show in
the thing i mean in all the
organizations yeah i think that he he he
likes it for sure i mean he i mean yeah
i think he definitely likes it yeah so
he's a supporter of arnold classic yeah
he's a supporter of the show yeah got it
yeah you said you said it would be
ridiculous i mean just think about this
18 months ago right like do we even have
a barometer for what is and isn't
ridiculous anymore i mean in jersey i
talked about this on the podcast a
couple weeks ago jersey this is a true
story they were having kids wrestling in
a wrestling tournament but for covid
reasons they weren't allowed to shake
hands before or after the mat
then wrestle each other oh my god for
eight minutes
that's crazy wrestle each other can't
shake hands after the match it's you
know because protocols so i mean what
like what exactly is ridiculous anymore
like what's common sense do we even have
a barometer on what it is and it isn't
no i mean the fact we were in new york
and they had asked for the vaccine
passport at the uh at the restaurant me
and my wife
and they're like well you can still sit
outside and we're like okay whatever
we're hungry right so we walk in through
the restaurant all the way through the
restaurant to outdoor area and they sit
down and i'm like well we just walked
all through the entire restaurant yeah
and then when they came back i'm like so
where do i go the bathroom she's like
what's in the back over there you just
go back yeah it's like that doesn't none
of it makes it chris rock telling
everybody get it but he got sick even
though he has it so get it so that
people don't get sick like the people or
maybe maybe we'll talk about what howard
stern said about rogan
uh uh and by the way apparently
my episode with rogan apparently just
went live like a a couple hours ago
competing against
because i'm getting text messages like
we're watching the podcast now your
podcast i'm like yeah uh all people are
clicking off now they're going over
there thanks for coming aaron
uh so so we got we got some stories to
cover with that but uh uh the one thing
i do want to talk about when you're
talking about mr olympia who's more
powerful
in the bodybuilding world jake wood or
jim manning oh jim mannion hundred
percent not even close not even even
though jake wood owns mr olympia it's
not even how does that work how does
that work how does jim manion have more
power than jake would jake what owns mr
olympia so how does everybody get to the
olympia they have to go to the npc and
then they have to go to ifbb pro league
shows they have to qualify for a pro
league show so if
there's no way the getting to the
olympia is the end result of all these
steps you have to go through first so if
you removed uh the everything in the
beginning nothing else exists got it so
a jim manion does he benefit from
the owner of olympia
doing a better job marketing with the
team he had that they have or germanium
doesn't give a [ __ ] because whether
olympia does well or not jim's going to
make his money no he cares for sure
jim's is still a huge bodybuilding fan
oh i know that for a fact i got to tell
you it doesn't matter who it is
everybody that i talk to when the name
jim mannion comes up
respect uh for that man at the highest
level and i'm talking including haters
yeah respect he's a jimmy yeah he's a
great he's a great guy look ultimately
for me i wouldn't even have told him
this before yeah i wouldn't be sitting
here talking to you if it wasn't for him
because i wouldn't have loved
bodybuilding i wouldn't have had that
outlet to go through i wouldn't be able
to go to all those shows with dave
palumbo all of it is really predicated
on his work erin what happens to mr
olympia if they go the way they're going
right now because to me
i watch some of their marketing i mean
they got some guys i've had meetings
with i watched some of their marketing i
mean
i
you know if they go the way they're
going right now
uh i have my own opinions i'm curious
you know you're in the world
you know i have a tendency of getting
myself and everybody around me in
trouble sometimes when we do interviews
but
what do you think is going to happen if
they go the way they're going right now
in regards to marketing well right now i
mean it's a super tough time to have
live events obviously the last year was
a loser because you couldn't couldn't
possibly make it profitable this one
that's coming up i know that they did
better with ticket sales and and uh with
expo stuff
um but i mean obviously the the big
thing is the expos in general are tough
in the future because people want to
have an experience you know the days of
waiting in line to meet jay cutler and
get him to sign an autograph are so
different now you can cj on your phone
and you can interact with them and you
can you know it's not no there's no
value in getting a photograph with jay
cutler sign right it's not the same
thing so there needs to be some
innovation in terms of like experience
like the nfl experience super bowl and
then you have an experience you're going
to there so i think there's something
more to be to be done with that in the
future it's got to because the old way
of the expo is going to is going to fade
away so if they go the way they're going
right now what could potentially happen
on the strolling of your brand well i
mean they go there the way they're going
right now the thing is is that jake wood
is a very wealthy guy and i think it
depends on his appetite for keeping
going you know
and like not being you know this is a
hobby and he loves it which i know is a
hobby and he loves it it just depends on
how how far he wants to take it unless
he does some stuff to change you know
it's interesting because you were
talking about it before the the kind of
the older business model was have a
great product first and then your brand
will evolve into your product like make
the best steak in town and then that'll
speak for itself and now in the digital
marketplace with social media like you
have to have a brand first like what's
our identity and then we'll find a
product to sell to that market that you
know identifies with our brand right so
it's it's kind of
it's it feels like uh the olympia from
my understanding is kind of that old
school mentality where hey look we're
still the best we're still the premier
name and bodybuilding and that should be
good enough that should stand alone and
that's that's kind of how you get past
passed by there's an entire generation
we were talking about this with phil off
the air when i was a kid i could name 10
bodybuilders i could name ten off the
top of my head i could name people that
never won i knew who marcus rule was i
knew gunther was he was in he was in
movies bodybuilders were in movies they
were in beer fest the guys did a good
job getting their bodybuilders on camera
and marketing them so people wanted to
go above and beyond for the guy that was
running the stroller i can't name three
active bodybuilders so who do you think
is going to compete in mr olympia this
year um who's going to win or is he's
going to go who's going to compete
brandon curry's won
by obviously rami brandon curry uh you
got uh
um
i mean
let's see i'm thinking of my guys you
got james holland's head is obviously
going to compete he just moved down to
boca for the next few weeks
which will be fun uh uh rooley is going
to be there really and then uh who just
backed out of the of the uh arnold uh is
the hottie guy howdy is going to be
there
william bonac thanks award william
bonack uh steve cuclow probably because
he's probably winning arnold because
they're missing a lot of people uh doing
arnold now who clue's going to win i
think for him great guy by the way a
great guy very good he was just here to
visit oh he's he's a fantastic guy i
like him a lot he's a great guy who do
you think is going to win it this year
uh i think big romney's going to win i
think again back to back i think so i
think so do you think he's going to go
on a run like a 5 6 7 8 tap of a run or
no i don't think so but i don't know but
the truth is there's a lot of young guys
that are up and coming now um
and uh
and it's hard to say sorry there's no
there's no like outlier so like when
phil was coming up he was an outlier we
looked at him and you're like dude this
guy's gonna win forever we don't have
anything like that do you have any
desire to purchase mr olympia yourself
and you run it since it's your world
sure of course you would want to do that
what would you do if you're running it
today uh i would do a lot of things you
don't want to give the idea because you
don't want them to they're like why
would you give it to them they gotta at
least give you
something to do it i would absolutely uh
like to do it would just be fun for like
i mean in terms of legacy i would like
to carry on that legacy uh one day you
know if if jake would didn't want to do
it anymore you know yeah do you think it
has what it takes to be a billion dollar
brand by itself
i don't know about that i don't know
about that the sort of bodybuilding i'm
not sure if it has that kind of first
off there hasn't been a real big push
you know they tried to do something uh
the rock tried to do something recently
with the rock show and stuff athletic
yeah which which is who knows they're
ever going to happen and then uh because
of covet stuff it's very difficult to
plan a huge event like that right now
and then um
and then the the fact that it is it
never really made it to tv so there was
one recently where they had like
everything set up and it was at the
olympia and they had many cameras and
and everything and for whatever reason
it didn't work out and it never got
aired i don't even know why but it was
supposed to be on
cbs sports or something like that being
off tv makes a big difference you know
when it was on tv it exposed a lot more
well there's a guy that's using tick
tock i forget his name i'll just try to
look it up real quick it's something
with a d he's hilarious he's really
funny he's either german or he's some
sort of western european and he's a
bodybuilder and he he's got like i think
seven and a half eight and a half
million followers on tick tock and he
oscillates back and forth between doing
training techniques and then like funny
little sketches and this is the guy that
does the chess stuff that uh yes
yes yes i don't know what his name is
they they say you cannot see he's not a
competitor though he's a he's a he's a
instagram
he's not
but he's got a ridiculous body he's got
a great force yeah he's not
which is which also makes bodybuilding a
little more difficult because why be a
bodybuilder when you can make more money
doing that
i have an idea if we ran mr olympia i
think the number one guys would make one
to three million every year and the
purse would be much bigger but that's if
we ran it but we don't i do other things
okay but if that was the case it'd be a
completely different thing and the sport
will be a little bit more creative
there'll be more fun there would be more
movies shows things like that but again
we don't again that's not our business
model we're not doing mr olympia and
jake wood is not selling the brand
anytime soon but if it ever does i think
you're a qualified guy so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye-bye
[Music]